but okay for people who are joining us
here this is a livestream about my day
job of working on design of or from
language are talking about something
that's part of the infrastructure for
supporting things like the physics
project this has to do with submitting
remote asynchronous jobs that can be
doing well all kinds of things all right
let me go ahead and run can I rerun this
in 12-1 just
in fact you have to be
okay so now that initialization will
take a couple a little while to finish
it that's to install some patents okay
okay so what this fundamentally is is a
way of setting up batch jobs this looks
pretty cool um
so I don't understand any of this this
looks very complicated to me so this
this remote submission environment
object here is a data structure that
that bundles together information that
tells a tells remote submit we're on a
provider that is Helios patch or charity
engine to submit a job in the case of a
linear spat you have to have a job queue
and the job definition and s3 bucket to
point to in charity in the case of
charity engine it's much simpler that
Association can be empty but creatively
as fast you have to have these these
server-side things that have to have
been pre-created which is a one-time
thing and I'm working on a method to
make a that those the streamlined
process for semi-automatically creating
that so you go to AWS you give them your
credit card or whatever and you then
does it in AWS account which you have to
have a credit card attached to but you
you would go into the AWS console and go
to the batch section and create a job
queue under some settings and you get
that stirring out you create a job
definition and do some settings get that
string out and as I said I'm working on
I'm making that that having a semi
automated way to do that I think he
mentioned possibly doing it in the form
notebook which I think at one time yeah
um it's a one-time setup thing you just
do it once in the lifetime of your
account or you can have multiple job
cues if you want there are advantages to
having multiple queues because you can
configure them different ways and use
whichever one you need at the time okay
um but so I mean should we maybe just
have a forum on the web where you go and
you put in I just don't know what's
involved here and um I don't really have
a sense of what this looks like and how
no well it's something that's associated
with your account so you have to be
authenticated and the way if it were
done in a forum notebook the way that we
work is we use AWS client the
other package I'm working on which
underlies remote submitted leaseback you
would use a Tobias client to handle
authentication and do a series of API
calls to create these his resources how
about a question from Brian on a live
stream asking about as you are I don't
know whether you've been I mean we have
all sorts of things going on with with
Microsoft and I would have expected that
this would sort of that those would turn
into sort of full support for a0 but I
don't know whether that's probably not
something you know about that's not
something I know about but that's
certainly a possibility this is an
extensible framework not user not
particularly user extensible but it is
it is modular so it would be assuming
Meserve provides a batch submission
system that's a wrapper on top of their
their compute infrastructure then it's
it's not a huge amount of work to to
create an integration the hardest part
would be handling something like
authentication in the majority API but
I'm already doing that for a couple yes
but so the authentication here is
something where how is the
authentication would write
authentication the version that you have
in that notebook is I'm sort of
tiptoeing around on less client contacts
with with some values but I'm working on
a fact I already have working very well
a service connection integration with
the AWS client package so you have an
AWS service and you authenticate using a
in the normal pop-up box that you get to
a dialog box to authenticate a service
connection and you put your key and
secret in there so that with that will
be how this works and there will be an
additional parameter to the remote
submission environment object which is a
service object so you can pass one in or
if you don't pass one in it will just
create one automatically and then it
will pop up and then it will then pop up
the web page asking you to a fun to code
it's not it's not a web page it's just
the dialog box and you paste in an
access key and access secret which are
the AWS credentials it's not a it's not
it's not oh ah I see
we have a standardized way of doing that
right of them of popping up an
authentication dialog yes that's correct
I'm not currently using that because it
wasn't quite flexible enough to do what
I what I need but that's just I thought
it was supposed to well okay I thought
it was supposed to have the possibility
that you can specify anything you want I
as far as I can tell it only supports a
single field in API in the case of AWS
you need to and actually it's slightly
it's more complicated than that because
in AWS client I also support automatic
automatic authentication which is where
it will there's a well-defined place a
file name dot AWS slash credentials in
your home directory where you can put a
file that has credentials that's what
the AWS command-line client looks into
so you with the AWS client package you
can you can choose automatic
authentication instead of manual and
then it will discover your credentials
from that file so it's it's even more
complex well there are more options than
just those two fields awesome so are you
documenting this with one of our
workflows or house that's being
documented it's not being documented at
all right now but it will be it's still
in development okay all right okay all
right so we have this remote submission
environment object okay okay so this is
the thing
imagine will be actually called remote
you're calling that remote job object
already so it will be remote job submit
probably right I discussed this a bit
with with Todd earlier this week and if
we are going to change the name what I'd
think oh the name I think is best to
something that Roman suggested which is
which would be batch submit and
everything would be prefixed with batch
because I think that's that's a little
clearer than and remote job it
distinguishes it even more from stuff
like remote evaluate and it also just it
prevents making the name even longer
question if you say batch submit do you
imagine that there will be a local
version of that at some point not not
exclusively local like on the local
machine I don't I don't imagine
supporting I don't expect to support
that I you you had you had said that
that you think it would be a good idea
to have something that people can set up
on their on their local network which i
think is a good idea i i still believe
that the best way to go about that is is
by supporting kubernetes as a remote
submission provider because that that
saves saves us save me from having to
reinvent the wheel sounds reasonable
Jason yeah I think that's fine I mean if
there a coupon that is is there a an
Orchestrator of orchestrators so to
speak that will let you ladies is that
kubernetes is the orchestrator on top of
it's a higher level of abstraction and
then and then docker kubernetes is the
the clustered abstraction that supports
having a like a manager instance and and
multiple work for instances and it will
it support scheduling like one-time
one-shot jobs which is what remote
submit deals miss okay okay so then what
that would look like from what you're
saying is you would have this would be
batch submit i'm almost you know I have
this great desire to say batch job
submit because I think I think that's
people understand what a bash
job is batch there are all kinds of
other batches that you know like
business concept the batch applied which
is a whole different thing where you're
you know batching is not the concept
here the concept is a batch job okay
with that what about remote map submit
because I'm I'm wearing of creating
these giant clunky names like that's job
map submit let's come to that in a
minute okay yeah but but then this
remote submission environment object
would be um batch job environment object
yeah the submission this submission
indicates that it well I mean maybe we
can get away with not have a saying
object here really I didn't think you
would say well I don't know it was
originally it was originally remote
submission environment but then I
realized that it would probably have to
be objects yeah environment kind of
gives the sense that it's some kind of
object thing right actually could we
could we get rid of submission just call
it space job environment object ask job
environment object is that I mean the
submission is that really necessary I
don't know I mean the environment it
would be bad job environment and there
may be a thing called batch job object
which represents the actual job itself
right right right yeah I do it is I'm
not sure but it is possible that adding
job in that makes submission redundant
but it's still batch job submit so
there's the submission look I think I
think the right thing is this thing
there and then it's batch job object
yeah lettuce represents the thing that
you've got that you're calling remote
job object here sure okay let me try
actually running it okay so and the fact
that the second argument that the that
the environment is the second argument
is kind of not obviously right to me
this is original
the first argument and then Roman and
Todd convinced me to move into the
second argument why because I think the
main reason was that it is it is
optional there is a symbol you can set
dollar default remote submission
environment and if you set that to a
remote submission environment then you
can home it the second argument of
remote Smith and it uses that and Romans
argument his argument was that having a
second argument that's optional is sorry
having a first argument having the first
argument of remote submit the optional
is kind of weird there's also the remote
evaluate and stuff like that test the
expo in the first argument so how did
remote evaluate get that why because but
for the same reason because the no sorry
no sorry
yes Wheatley motive al you ate this East
if it's the same and parallel evaluate
is the same so it's the first argument
well parallel evaluate was done like 15
years ago and it was done that way
because one expected that most of the
time people would have a default
parallel environment yes now if we
motive al you ate it's not so clear that
the default is all that useful I mean
they they love obviously be a default
from our kernel but I would expect to
remote evaluate to be mostly used in the
two argument form so so I also it
wouldn't matter but I mean we probably
cannot have something which is con
consistence who all established use
cases anyway so I personally would
prefer to say machine comma X per for
remote evaluate because I think that's
what I mean if we look at for example um
what about remote process what is that
called process process yes but at
process yeah remote run process those
those I believe do have the IP that was
what I modeled my original after I think
it should be the machine in the first
argument I think that the parallel case
is odd because so much of the time it
will be default
whereas remote evaluate almost none of
the time will it be default yes now this
case I think this should be flipped
around I really did feels unnatural to
me in this order then again you probably
only work with one remote submission
environment at a time so you might have
a dollar default remote submission
remote environment and so you would be
back with the single parallel evaluate
the single single argument case I know
but it's like the block chain case where
where in principle you're always doing
it with one block chain but in practice
I find myself really quite often you
know not explicitly setting maybe I just
don't like setting global variables but
um all right let's keep going here so
we've got so Ethan on the live stream is
asking about um how does this relate to
tasks I think we're going to find that
out right well I don't describe it
specifically in here but I mean yes
there are there are some fairly
fundamental differences okay um hunts on
the live stream is talking about a batch
job jacket wear a jacket is the envelope
in metal objects necessary to run a
batch job um I think that's related to
this I don't think it's a so much of a
jacket as as a as a location to send the
batch job into right it's a location
it's basically the configuration that
goes in because there's you can also
supply certain um bits of configuration
to remote submit directly the
configuration that goes into the
environment as opposed to in remote
submit directly is the configuration
that is that I generally expect to be
almost always persistent across multiple
jobs so in the case of AWS patch it's
that job queue and stuff in the case of
charity engine there is one optional
configuration parameter that called use
owned devices which tells you tells it
whether to submit it only to the devices
that are owned by you in person
you the user so that's again something
that you can use across multiple jobs
most likely okay is there a way of
cutting like a dataset with all of these
things showing no there isn't and it's
because most of those require a network
clearing um and and also could
potentially be extremely large like
gigabytes because evaluation data has
the result I could have a data set
that's that's just the static stop
wellbut motion or something what - of
Trotwood well you can do yeah you can do
that that works oh that's it is that is
just the static stuff that's very cool
okay so this is cautious is complicated
well if you go down a bit there's the
job status you can get which by now it
should be should be finished why is this
not a successful trip time because the
status is the string that's returned
directly from AWS batch and the set of
strings that can be returned there
varies across providers given that we're
calling this batch job object do we
really need the job and the sum and here
that was modeled after tasks objects
where the property is task status mm-hmm
okay
explain why a job object is not a task
object and because it's mostly for for
implementation reasons the
implementation of tasks objects differs
a lot from from what makes the most
sense for remote job objects if you look
at a remote job object the input form of
it it's just it's just a data structure
that includes stuff like the UI that's
never gonna be a good argument the
argument that it's easier to implement
it's never a good argument so what is
there a different I mean if I say cloud
submit of you know pause seven or
something
I'm getting back a task object and by
the way there's a bunch of differences
here why oh I see if I say information
of that hopefully oh come on that should
be made to work but okay so you're
telling me and I don't understand why
the information well whatever this this
seems inconsistent and I don't know why
this header is so big here is whose
project management collar yes am um so
I'm complaining about that I'm
complaining about the fact their colons
here and there aren't colons here and I
think learning about the fact that
information doesn't work on a task
object but ok Jesse keep going on me
because there's tons of stuff here that
seems irrelevant to a task object but I
don't quite understand why the the main
queries here like status and so on are
they the same between tasks and batch
jobs or are they not well well for I may
have been consistent as much as I could
just for convenience it makes sense for
thee for 2,000 its task status for tasks
object everything job status work job
object um but there are indeed a lot of
differences there are a lot of
properties that are not that are on
remote job objects they're not on task
objects because they fundamentally don't
apply and there are also some properties
aren't that many properties of tasks
object there are some that that are done
remove job object alright so here's a
question from Ethan our live stream can
you take a task object and run it on a
remote machine as a batch job at a
subject and not not directly as a test
object represents a task that has
already been submitted whether it be
local or to the orphan so your point is
that it's the same thing you can take an
expression just like you can say cloud
submit I can say batch job submit all
that expression correct ok so I see so
here's an evaluation result so if I now
say batch
- it's about remote what is it remote
submit yes remote submit okay do I have
to give the environment here yes yes
okay
remote submit oh I don't know dollar
machine name environment okay so get
back a remote job object I say
job job yeah percent 127 sub okay so now
let's say I say evaluation result I
don't know whether it ran yet I think
it's probably okay not yet check the
status okay and by the way that missing
not available I actually I will it will
put thee it will have the status in it
cuz you can have a second argument to
missing that's like metadata I um but I
had to remove it temporarily I think it
should be missing who do you think it
should be a failure object it's not well
the evaluation result is what you're
asking for and the evaluation result is
missing it's not there yet people are
live stream are definitely not liking
the distinction between task and job um
and the way I understand it is that our
tasks are currently tied very directly
to the act what their current uses
including Colonel internal stuff and so
on so what would be involved would be to
make that account tasks into a kind of
abstract class are we talking in a
fermentation astir are we talking a
designer's dream it okay I don't care
about that the fact that this is I mean
that's not a good argument the question
is from the point of view user design
what makes the most sense right in other
words when this comes back as a remote
job object why is it not coming back as
a task object
well as I said the main reason is
implementation wise but what makes the
most sense from a design perspective is
probably for to have them be the same
thing to have remote submit return a
task object but if that were the case
there would be a huge suite of
differences between the the properties
and behavior of the of a task object
from from local submit cloud submit etc
and a task object okay in particular
what are they probably it there are
dozen more properties potentially a
dozen more properties a remote remote
remote job object if it's submitted if
it comes from the road maps in it it can
represent an array job that has child
job objects so we have we have to be
some way of returning child tasks
objects it would be it would be a big
headache documentation if nothing else
because there would be it would had
someone mentioned bifurcation
essentially be a bifurcation in the in
the documentation page for task object
here's how it works for remote submit
here's how it works for everything else
okay so let me just understand that tell
me if I go to task object right now and
I think your job is finished by the way
okay but if I go to task object right
now these properties of task object
they're listed here which ones of these
apply to batch jobs evaluation results
task environment task status task type
tasks UUID
now right now we don't have a scheduled
batch task that's right that's that
that's that would be significantly more
complicated to to support okay I mean
the main issue here is not you know
having a function batch jobs submit with
all kinds of tentacles you know that's
okay because that's like saying you know
local submit session submit and so on to
is whether the returned object okay I
understand the implementation but that's
not what the issue is the issue is from
a user point of view
I think a big big question though is
whether your if we made these into task
objects would they support the task
object API which is task abort test
execute tasks remove tasks resume you
know all the task functions can they
meaningfully work on your remote job
objects only tasks aboard and
potentially tasks removed but it would
mean something we'd be semantically
different tasks Espanyol doesn't make
sense
tasks resume doesn't okay so Tosca board
how do you do task abort right now
remote job abort oh for goodness sake
okay let's take a look here at my so I
should be able to say where was my
training
okay so percent 127 evaluation result oh
I had it right now okay just a little
thing about drop status now you said
that the return value depends on the on
the back end which makes sense but it
still would be useful to have a standard
where you're finding out whether it
finish there is there is talk suggested
this theory the properties
job succeeded Q job failed Q and job in
progress Q which returns balloons which
there's no point in us trying to I mean
it's just a blob of text basically
correct and it's useful if something
goes goes horribly wrong and something
crashes cuz this is this will still be
their job because it's a direct and we
don't have any similar such thing for
our task objects right correct doesn't
make any sense for task objects
why not because the this is a this is
the standard out of a process task task
objects don't have processes unless
they're sub Colonels and even man I
don't think anything's going to standard
that okay but we do have something like
this for cloud submit there is an output
page you know for clouds in the past
where he say I haven't seen in a long
time I don't remember what's in it but I
know where is it where is it how do I
get to it yeah
it's like the URL for the cloud object
for the class when you do a cloud and
submit you get a tossed object yeah I
think in the task object there must be a
cloud object that has been then you can
go to to see the progress I'm not seeing
it used cloud spit in there is a there's
something in a generator um that gives
you a report my gosh every single person
who's joining this live stream is asking
what's the difference between a task and
a job this is not a good sign
um but I do think let's go back I mean
let's talk about the task if yeah if if
the tasks API all the functions that
operate on tasks you know most of them
don't work with these things that's a
good argument that they shouldn't be
tasked well it's not that good an
argument if you have to have your own
sort of shadow version of a batch job
abort like that all right
the fact of the alternative for what
it's worth I also support a task board
you can cast boarding remote job object
it works it's not document now you're
really confusing so the proper way to do
it would be to design a generic tasks
API that covers all the cases we now
looking at and then we implementing our
account tasks in terms of that and there
we know job in terms of that well I mean
cosmetically how difficult would it be
for you to just make this be a task
object with certain I could do it but it
would be it would be a major major hack
it would not be it would not be done
correctly to do it correctly would
require completely tearing out the how
implementation of test object I believe
I'm not sir
and what about other AWS another cloud
provider services that aren't batch
services I understand it but I want to
know what they will look like because if
they correspond to something you know
yet a different mechanism for
maintaining the state of the cloud
providers you know let's say you spin up
a machine in in Azure or whatever and
you're going to do things with it what
does that look like here I understand
that this doesn't look like anything
because this is just a batch queue and
you you know the fact what machine you
get is kind of irrelevant right I know
all those things synchronous operations
just all those other things are
synchronous operation yeah well yes once
you spun up a machine spinning something
up and and evaluating you know look for
example you could spin up a container
with the Wolfram application server in
it and be talking to that and there will
be service signing they may already
exist service execute things for
spinning up for initiating yeah I don't
know exactly all those will work and I
don't know whether those are related at
all to this I don't believe they they
are I do have I mean I can show you I
have to send it to you but I can show
you what service objects AWS service
objects look like but they're not I mean
that's a lower-level way of accessing
AWS it guys whether it be an alias batch
or some other one of the other 200
services at lower level than remote
submit notes and it is a a provider
independent as much as possible wrapper
emits a fairly standardized okay this
thing here I'm I suggested this but I
don't know whether we want to be as
general as that so you know look what
what I'm concluding here is that this
concept of a batch job what's really
bothering me is if we want to change
this some point in the future
and have this merge with tasks what
would have to happen is batch job submit
would have to start returning a task
object instead of a batch job object but
you see I think this could go in two
different ways I think it could be that
there's a whole different world of batch
jobs that itself gets a lot of
complicated hair and that we're going to
be very happy we have a separate batch
job submit because we can put all that
hair in there without having to you know
make the toss interface more complicated
that's one possibility the other
possibility is that people will view
these just like tasks that you can
submit on local machines and so on and
that then we will want to merge it with
with sort of more local task objects um
well I for one am certain that I that I
would be happy have something else that
can grow as much hair as as it needs so
that's what I suspect we should end up
doing and that a batch job I mean we
should describe this as being for now a
remote batch job
I think that's literally what it says on
the page okay alright okay well fine
okay let's take a look here because this
guide page gonna work yes it goes good
well thanks um okay remote batch jobs
okay so this becomes oh boy just like we
have to have a tasks function a list of
submitted jobs so is that something that
I would say so this would say remote
jobs and the kind of say open closed or
do I have to say they're like if you do
open closed it uses the default of
course these are all things I've
submitted because we're on the same
account okay so are they finished
or do they indicate that they're
finished here not in there you'd have to
query the job status but you can say
remote jobs and I think you can give
that as the second argument you can give
a status like
seated and it will query only they will
give you all the jobs in that Matt
status
oh no I'm wrong about that sorry the
second ranking there's something else
why does this not come back and right
into some table somewhere when it knows
that one of these jobs is finished why
doesn't it do that and be able to modify
what this blob looks like I think
because that wouldn't well you're not
suggesting having it be dynamic just how
I'm not having a day I'm saying that it
writes that once it knows that it can
indicate that this thing has Bennet I
mean I would like to be able to get a
list of the active jobs right well okay
there's this isn't okay there is
something I should mention which is for
AWS match finished completed jobs
whether they succeeded or failed only
stay around for 24 hours so this this
list will give you all running jobs and
all finished jobs that have finished in
the last 24 hours okay so by the way so
people are complaining still complaining
about jobs versus versus tasks and that
I mean okay let's take a look a little
bit more here and do you have a charity
engine version of this also not if
remote maps in it only remote I submit
there can we see the remote submit for
chart engine and it looks exactly the
same but you can go into the remote
submit RF page I think there's an
example under scope or and quickly link
for provider pages charity engine so
this is a mock-up of pages that will
beams like like entity refuges that are
for reference for specific providers
that have that document everything
that's specific to that provider so you
can check under examples there should be
you should see it looks the remote
submit though it looks as after the same
okay explain from the beginning why yeah
I mean so hands-on our live stream is
pointing out that jobs are a more
sophisticated concept than tasks and
that in principle a job could contain
tasks not in a not in any native way and
but you could you could do tasks you can
do local submitted sessions submit
within a job if you so wish I'm not sure
why you'd want to do that but yes that
is that is possible that's which is not
something that fits into the existing
design problem is these providers and I
I don't know you know you should if you
haven't looked at the azure case there's
certainly a bunch of people in the
company who know about there's your case
and you probably check with them um but
you know the fact that you managed to
get this framework to work with both AWS
and charity engine I think is a good
sign because they are somewhat different
kinds of things um okay let me just
understand this map submit thing
um someone here is pointing out that
they like c-sharp and pythons async a
way to pattern that's much more what we
have for tasks this is not an this is a
batch job it's not a task that has you
know our our tasks system has all these
kinds of handlers and callbacks and so
on this has no callback possibility
whatsoever this is a thing where it's
being sent to you know a random machine
in the darkest data center in the world
type thing to get executed and I want to
mention one other user level difference
between jobs and and tasks which is just
a matter of how they're used it's
perfectly reasonable to have a batch job
that runs for several days while that's
probably technically supported in the
task framework but but it's not
something that you would normally you
would normally do at least how tasks
work right now well because tasks tend
to be attached to a particular session
they have to be attached to a particular
session that is a that is a
implementation detailed but that is a
fundamental detail of how task objects
work cloud task objects are calling
tasks is something which is anchored to
a session whereas a job is something
that is just running out there in the
world independent of I mean it's not
quite right because a scheduled task is
not anchored to a session a scheduled
process it's not it runs in the car I've
had scheduled plus I wanna class yes yes
sure right
but still it's I'm I'm pretty sure it's
it's kind of hard to recover results
from a cloud task object that's in a
session other than the one from from
which it's the handlers will not work
the handlers are a different thing
perhaps they're intended for a thing
that has a you know has a handle to that
particular object to that particular
task and then you can have callbacks and
so on working from that task yeah let's
understand remote map submit what is
this doing subdued this is creating an
array job on AWS batch that contains
multiple child jobs this is the this is
how you'd handle a situation where you
have maybe several million items in a
list and you want to apply a function to
each like you might use map or parallel
map now you don't want to submit one job
that that does all those fifty million
whatever because that will take a while
there's a limit on how fast that can get
because there's a limit on how many CPUs
you can have attached to a single job
but you also don't want to submit fifty
million individual jobs because that's
that overloads overwhelms what what
these back providers are capable of
doing they won't let you do it so this
this will this automatically chunks up a
big list into multiple smaller lists and
submits each one as a child job of an
array job an array job is something
that's natively supported in AWS
management so the visualization there
shows you which part was horrible font
but yes it has not been designed it's
okay okay fine
Oh
job packing position so too is this ness
table many levels or what no um it's
only but it might if the packing is more
complex can you go to the the remote map
submit ref age please I linked in the
guide page um there's some an example of
those visualizations from more complex
packing strategies because you can
customize how it and how do these
packing strategies relate through our
parallel evaluate they are they are
modeled directly off of them but they
are not the same and why are they not
being I mean our parallel evaluation
stuff has a different display well it
doesn't have it any display is it well
it has it has a Status page it has a
status thing you can bring up it's
showing you what's it doesn't show you
how its clustered or it shows what the
Colonel's are doing but it's not related
to a units but that means obviously now
that we are using these visualizations I
mean it would certainly make sense for
me to add stuff like that to a parallel
code can you go down to the method under
under the options section examples
examples oh boy yes that's a grid of of
child jobs of which there are ten here
with two blanks yeah
max pointed that out too that I should
not have the mesh in the blank section
that's just that didn't okay and doesn't
doesn't divide doesn't go into a square
okay what am I looking actions method I
unfortunately to wrap this meeting very
very soon um I think okay look that the
gosh the
important thing I mean you've managed to
get all this stuff actually working is
that the basic picture here correct
that's very nice
um there are clearly some okay so this
batch job map submit that is a very
weird concept I mean why why I mean it's
like parallel mat right so conceptually
you submit I mean what you what you
really want is something like remote
submit off map F comma X but you want
that map to be done on the outside and
so it will distribute
the jobs into partial right right the
parallel stuff provides you is more
full-featured and actually like looking
into an expression and figuring out how
to paralyze I'm I'm I just support math
at one level you can't do multiple
levels it's um it's it's it's pretty
pretty basic so um like I want to move
you know right the issue here is okay
you know we've got parallel map which is
doing something different
I mean we've got three different
mechanisms here we've got parallel
kernels
we've got tasks and now we've got jobs
now the truth is in the general world of
computing these things are handled
somewhat differently and I can't mention
there can also be parallel kernels
inside a job and you could say parallel
map inside a parallel map inside a batch
job map submit not inside of remotely a
batch dog maximun you can do parallel
map inside remotes of a for remote Maps
event you can tell it you can give it
that same provider settings option and
set a new CPU number and then it will
automatically just use parallel map
instead of map inside each job cuz each
job will have multiple CPUs available to
boy this is complicated but that bad
aspect is it is abstracted away from the
user that's not so let me ask a
practical question so if I'm doing like
some random machine learning training
what do it what is my actual workflow I
mean am I am i uploading a ton of stuff
like for AWS to as three and then I'm
just saying which I represent by some
kind of external stee uploading to s3 is
handled automatically and I in the in
the agenda then you go out to remote
submit the end of the remote submit
section there's a down down input files
so you can specify a local file to be
uploaded alongside your your job code
and then it's made available it's
automatically downloaded into the
working directory before it launches
into your code so you can record it but
if you don't want to deal with files you
can also with our that has include
definition semantics so you can also
just have a variable in your session
that's already defined that has a bunch
of stuff in it you can use that in your
code so what you're doing is you're
creating essentially a local file system
this job input files creates is is
specifying in the same way that files
system scan or file system map lets you
have a list of I'm still a little bit
confused because that's the content find
file is just fine it's yes yeah I
understand the path so it's not the
content so this is a mapping between
your a sort of chroot I'd lo chol file
system in the batch job and files on
your machine that this is coming it's
it's very simple it doesn't support
directories or anything you can just you
just give it a name um but I think I
think that's I think that's sufficient I
think yeah I took it to simplify
uploaded the file is local right yeah
and I should mention you can also give a
byte array instead of a
a little of that a few so um okay and
you mentioned external storage object if
you scroll down a little bit more there
is something that's not implemented yet
but what I hope I hope to have this I
hope to integrate this input file system
with the external storage system but
there are external storage is currently
not extensible um I have to wrap this
meeting I have another one coming up in
just a few minutes here and I need my
lunch
um the this is look there's a lot of
really nice stuff here there were a few
design changes that we know we need
based on this um I I think we still need
to spend a bit more time with this but I
mean this is definitely coming to
closure um
I think you really should look at these
your stuff people there all right have
to go here okay thanks to folks on the
livestream for your input and